all right it is time for drew's news and
with me at the desk every girl's dream
co-pilot ross matthews yes
hi everybody
i made that up on the fly and then i was
like your girls boys men women you're
everybody's dream co-pilot darling yeah
that's right i'm a man to dream of
you're gosh darn tootin right that you
are okay i'll take it thank you man take
it thank you well i'm really excited
because we have got huge holiday feasts
for your peepers
because the mir reports that one family
in germany has broken the record for
most decorated christmas trees in one
place with 444
trees in their own home
what
the jeromeans beat their own record last
year that's right they beat the
jeromeans themselves the jeromeans extra
romans yeah they kicked their own
christmas butt because last year they
only had a measly 420 trees
mr drummond hauls the trees out of the
attic starting in august and it takes 47
000 lights and 10 000 decorations to
make each tree unique i mean take a look
you can see the visuals right here
because i gotta tell you
it's better than what was in my head
this is real commitment ross thought
makes me feel pretty crappy about my one
plastic christmas tree
and can you guys do that thing where
it's time to decorate the tree and it
sounds really fun and like by ornament
four you're like oh god that has to do
that
and then you don't even decorate the
back and all you're thinking about all
christmas long is about how you have to
take it down on
how long does this guy spend removing
these trees
if he brings it out in august let's do
the math probably by march
he probably has only like six months off
a year well
congratulations on your trees all right
i'm like exhausted for you
i'm impressed it's very impressive i'm
exhausted well next you know if you're
looking for some holiday hair
inspiration something that will really
stand up and stand out
the bouffant is back oh yeah baby vogue
reports that hairstyle that marie
antoinette started oh 200 years ago well
it's poofing up everywhere look at
duolifa boofed it up at the brit awards
tessa thompson looking very breakfast at
tiffany by the way lady gaga heard of
her
no stranger to the befant and of course
there are so many bouffants through the
ages bridgette bardot oh i love her uh
the supreme oh my goodness i love them
jackie oh oh i love her and what about
drew barrymore
yeah yeah i you've had bouffants before
look at that
yeah yeah you remember this hairstyle i
remember this hairstyle yeah yeah it was
at the sag awards uh-huh that hair was
epic does it take a long time to get
that sort of well i actually asked mr
daniel um and he's gonna do a social
post that i'm gonna put on my channel
where he's gonna teach you how to create
the bouffant i was like wait we have
this like famous hairdresser who does
your gorgeous hair i've worked with him
for 20 years mr daniel he's done he's
worked with all these incredible women
and and he's just so talented anyway i'm
going to do a video with him and he's
going to take you through it so go on my
channel
this story i thought was very cute and
just a little morsel for your day
it's that time of year for ice skating
check out benny people reports that this
eight-year-old rescue dog just won an
excellence award from the american club
for his work because he skated for
children with autism
and other
disabilities and benny was also on a
euthanasia list in utah at a shelter but
look at him now
and if this just doesn't give you hope
for different outcomes it is possible
i don't know what does so here is my
personal gem for you benny we love you
thank you you give me hope
about everything
um
i've tried ice skating one time and it
turns out i have petite ankles so i
can't
thank you very much
that's what they told me i was like i'll
take it really yeah you know what i have
cankles you do not one of the things
that i've always coveted like body part
wise because i'm like okay this is what
i got i'm gonna try to work with it and
not have like you know a bunch of issues
with it
waste my life work with what i've got
sure but thin little ankles
next lifetime you're on my list yeah
my weight has gone up and down but my
ankles have always been at my goal
weight all the way good for you rosie
thank you i could also do without this
arm flap right here that's also going on
the list for next year but i got other
assets so i'm happy yeah you do
all right up next we've got your food
forecast it's time for food news
all right
you know this one excites me i know
you're excited we love food around here
and the year's not even done but we're
already looking forward to what we're
going to eat next year
better homes and gardens reports yelp
has released their 2022 food forecast
and there are all kinds of food trends
you're going to see soon how about this
something called a pizza
cone yeah okay i'm here for you people
slap of hands who would eat a pizza cone
and just to be very clear so you know
what it is it is pizza that's been
shaped into a cone and the toppings like
drip into it with the cheese and all
i will be having a pizza cone yeah 20
22. no questions yes what about this
i'll i'll see your pizza cone and raise
you a crawful it's a cross between a
croissant and a waffle from south korea
they say oh the audience is excited they
say it's going to be everywhere and
guess what it's here right now
look what we have now does everybody
remember the dominic ansel craze the
cronut yeah the donut croissant thing
yeah yeah i think it was like that food
frankenstein moment that basically
started off all these new trends like he
changed the world with that cronut and
so a lot of food trends have like
matriculated into trying to be the
cronut sure and i'm like listen you want
to put one thing with the other food
wise do it
well
this is interesting mine this one looks
savory look it's got tomatoes and like a
pesto thing going on what look right
here it's right there right there that
whoa i was not expecting like a savory
approach to the what is it called
crawful
see what i i when i need to work on that
name it sounds a little
like you're so crawful i can't even
handle you right now i am crawfully
excited to try this one
oh
whoa
can we talk texture oh my god this is
this is not gonna let you down
no oh my god and you know that this is
according to um yelp the number one food
trend for 2022.
like this rated number one get your own
well this is crawfordly good and i am
here for it
[Music]
you